[Music]
it's an instinctive
together
and [ __ ] fear it's the destiny of the
Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
I'm doing there is repeal I'm taking one
last look at my friends
yes maybe forever
[Music]
this Christmas
[Applause]
it's okay that we're here it's okay that
you're here did she do that to us
[Music]
starwars the rise of Skywalker this is
not yet rated and fronting fear it's the
destiny of a Jedi your destiny it's this
mission fails it was all for nothing
[Music]
we're not alone good people will fight
if we leave them
[Music]
your journey yes it's it
our Wars the rise of Skywalker tickets
available now
oh we've done all this time we're doing
there's repeal taking one last look sir
my friend
[Music]
confronting fear
is the destiny of the Jedi your destiny
we're all in this
tool and Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
tickets available now
[Music]
confronting fear is the destiny of a
Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
the force will be with you always
[Applause]
tickets available now
you